Let's look at the solution to our
virtual index physically tagged cache,
aliasing avoidance quiz.
We won't know aliasing,
which means the index bits have
to come from the page offset.
The page, has 2 to the 13th bytes,
so the page offset has 13 bits.
In the address breakdown for
accessing the cache,
that means that the index and offsets
for the cache need to fit in 13 bits.
The 16-byte block size means that
the cache block offset is 4 bits.
That's how many bits we need to tell
us where in the 16 bytes we are, and
that means that we have 9 bits for
the index.
We can use fewer, but
that would make the cache even smaller.
We cannot use more,
because then we will get aliasing.
So the maximum cache size will be
when it has 2 to the 9th sets.
So we have 2 to the 9th sets times
2 to the 4th bytes in each block,
times it's a four-way
set-associative cache,
so we have 2 to the 2nd,
four blocks in a set.
So this is basically bytes per block,
blocks per set, how many sets?
And that amounts to 2 to
the 15th bytes in the cache, so
the answer here is 32 kilobytes,
which is 2 to the 15th bytes.
So we cannot have a cache that is
larger than 32 kilobytes and yet
it avoids aliasing
with these parameters.
Note that really these two have
to be equal to the page size
because 2 to this number of bits
times 2 to this number of bits,
has to be equal to 2 to
this number of bits.
So really, the maximum size of
the cache here is the page size
times the associativity.
And the only way to avoid
aliasing in a cache,
while making it larger,
is to increase associativity.